deixa eu tirar uma foto aqui por meu
enepe cheque perdeu o objeto é igual a
fotinha e também por nf é tão viciado
essa botnet é tá público mp já quem
quiser me seguir esse que aparece na
tela beleza é [ __ ] igaci time do
planalto bom vocês como está muito bem
porque quem está bem
o ifs conta pra gente está bem que eu
vim fazer um show em picos meus amigos
picos picos piauí no meu piauí el e
terra querida filha dos ong é quanto e
quando não brasil brasil brasil quer nem
mostra da positiva nenhuma de fazer um
show aqui um barato não fala aqui né
daqui a pouco inclusive fazer no caso
quando você estiver assistindo já passou
mas tem várias oportunidades para pessoa
por exemplo a galera de cuiabá cuiabá no
mato grosso
xuxa fazer um show em cuiabá no dia 13
de junho às quatro horas da tarde no
holiday em um cd com versões de lá o
cara eu tenho ingresso para comprar o
ingresso gpi ingresso na casa de festas
do goiabeiras shopping e do pantanal
shopping só ir lá nós linhas isso não
vai ter ao exibir que ia de são paulo
tem sim a desgraça em são paulo dia 18
de julho ingressorapido.com.br show em
são paulo comprou é nóis valeu é nós
vamos ao vídeo você está enrolando
demais é desculpa se propagando a gente
existe muito nome estranho no mundo
agora igual ao meu acho que não há
humano em um item mas nós que inscreve
igualmente não wh e nds wh e asterisco
jogar meu nome é muito complicado não é
toda uma rede wifi é proteger sua
internet dos vizinhos bote meu nome como
sem nenhuma não tem no mundo quem que e
aí mulher como é que tá eu tô bem bonito
pois é mulher também também é e foi aqui
tem é assim em cinco é assim é o inverso
a senha de uso do 3g mental tive muita
dificuldade em aprender meu nome eu só
fico feliz quando eu percebi que tem
gente que tem história mais dramática do
caminho quando chove nega
ele vai aprender a escrever o nome dele
um dia desses o botafogo vai ficar
melhor que aqui fica melhor e eu sofri e
ainda sofro tá gostoso eu ainda sou
muito bullying porque eu te ensino
principalmente quando eu vou em
aeroporto porque aeroporto não sei se
vocês sabem mas quando você está
entrando para embarcar a mulher
mulherzinha do aeroporto ela pega sua
identidade ela olha essa identidade ela
analisa em detalhes o photo a vencer
você meio e ela diz em alto e bom som
boa noite ricardo muito obrigado você
viajar pela nossa companhia aérea boa
viagem vou sempre tá ela pega no carro
que está atrás dele é boa noite e
maurício muito obrigado por você
escolher nossa companhia aérea boa
viagem volte sempre da pedra do próximo
à noite pedro muito obrigado por você
escolher nossa companhia aérea boa
viagem voto sempre tarde ela pega a mim
faz assim
boa noite
bob ágil a paz só é nóis eu às vezes eu
muitas vezes fiquei profundamente
magoado assim conter esse nome que eu
chegava pra minha mãe falava assim me
disse pode falar pra mim pode falar
foi um sorteio que foi uma aposta que a
senhora perdeu que foi na verdade o
widerson até existe só que escreve igual
e se não existem aqui olha minha
identidade fosse meu deus do céu 2s na
identidade e quem é que bota 2 é o nome
de um filho é esse o meu filho é o
seguinte pobre não pode ver as coisas de
guerra quanto é é de graça essa letra e
por pote 5 ruim ou não button não bota
wwf massa e propaganda e bota 6 ela fala
morreu o imea o inem é a pessoa
ganhadora é vencedor venceu o iene é
vencedor venceu a peça vencedora só que
aí vem alguém e de uma opinião de
colocar um som no final jorge jorge jair
jailson então vencedor do começo que eu
ganhei no começo eu perdi no final agora
é bom que o nome um nome diferente não é
confundir o inverso você pode chegar com
aeroporto lotado de gente chama no
microfone o inversão não tem outra
pessoa só tem eu e é um nome tão incomum
e um atentando ensino que ele pode
chamar no aeroporto de macapá fla no
piauí com o topo até alguém me chamou e
ele pega o stoke teu nome é um nome de
impacto é o nome que dá um susto e falam
eu acho que tem tem nome mas de mais
impacto que o meu por exemplo a filha
vai apresentar o namorado o país pai
está aqui meu namorado apagadas assim
qual é seu nome rafael josé wesley é de
que wesley safadão o painel diz o meu
deus do céu eu entrei eu [ __ ] da minha
filha é um cara com o nome wesley
safadão e tirou a virgindade por
bluetooth
acho que que porque eu porque eu tenho
um nome estranho eu peguei uma
dificuldade de decorar a fim esse nome
de dupla em dupla tipo bruno e marrone
não sei qualquer marrom em qualquer um
dos dois é de camargo luciano sequer
zezé de camargo e luciano são de junho
eu não sei qual dos dois também da
república se sabe nessa fartamente saber
quando diz que se você presenteia ato na
fila do supermercado aí quem é que você
vê lá na frente do caixa o junho você
fala meu deus do céu pega o celular
ganhar voto na cama chega perto da
pessoa
sandy junior tirar foto comigo a
diversão a sandes e tira foto com a
sandy chega em casa
eu tirei uma foto com o som de junho eu
não sei que é certo é menor que é fabia
s2000 já tem um que tem a massa corporal
de 3 nesses sites menores fabiano eller
que que eu vou fazer lei não ele américa
sua música chico será o leilão de um
coração nunca daquele tamanho que o
minho que aliam 16gb decoração e as
pessoas sempre me pego mais lindas
afinal por que que a tua mãe colocou
esse nome você e eu costumo dizer a
mesma resposta todo mundo eu acho que é
só porque time eu acho que é só porque
dá um pouquinho
mas é isso aí galera muito obrigado você
quer assistir esse vídeo até aqui já
está no facebook tem um amigo que tem um
nome estranho marca nos comentários ele
vê curte a postagem para me ajudar a não
pode esquecer que o dia 13 de junho
agora eu vou estar em cuiabá no dia 21
está em manaus do dia 21 e votar em boa
vista está como é fácil comprar ingresso
pro show onde é que vai ser papa tudo
que na descrição do vídeo que gostei de
você tiver gostar vai me ajudar muito se
inscreve no canal sem nunca perder o
vídeo novo muito obrigado valeu e até
mais